foreign
I apologize for the delay I had to
confer with my other half before we
begin if you could please rise and join
I pledge allegiance to the flag of the
United States of America and to the
Republic for which it stands one nation
under God indivisible with liberty and
with that we're going to begin our
subcommittee work
on the bail bills
HP 38 HB 318 HP
653 Senate bill number 252 and Senate
bill number two excuse me 249.
for the purposes of the for the
committee I'd like to lay out what my
thoughts are and what I've discussed
with um
with representative Harry gathright
on how the framework of this is going to
go going forward over the next
three to four weeks we're going to meet
twice a week and we're going to go over
a series of issues that we're going to
incorporate into each of these bills
which will cause a considerable rewrite
of most of them however we will be
incorporating most of the issues in
these bills
probably just in different ways so the
first issue we're going to go over not
today but these are the issues we'll be
dealing with is we're going to be
looking at appropriating money
and I'll be inviting finance that day
that we talk about it
to totally revamp and update the it
system for the criminal justice and
court system in the state of New
Hampshire
it's 2023 and the majority of our court
system functions like it's in the early
2000s maybe earlier they're heavily
paper driven there's huge disconnects
between the different courts between the
courts and probation parole police
and in this day and age we should be
able to have real-time information
when a warrant is entered or when a
warrant is canceled
um bail is issued bails rescinded
conditions of bail this should all be
available instantly to the law
enforcement across the state so
I've invited several
companies that have done this in other
states they're going to come and give us
a presentation it's not our role to
decide which company does what or who is
hired to do what it's our job to talk
about the policy and we'll pass it to
finance to appropriate and the courts
will decide who they want to deal with
the purpose of having them come is so
that we have an understanding of what
they can provide versus where we are now
so we have a firm understanding of what
we're dealing with
so that's going to be one of the issues
the next issue and probably one of the
most important we're going to deal with
is how the bail Commissioners are paid
or more appropriately how they're not
paid we've heard testimony over years
that they're getting paid somewhere
between 40 and 50 and I would defer to
my colleague about how often they get
actually paid for the work they do
part of our work is going to be ensure
that these folks are paid
these folks get up in the middle of the
night they drive sometimes many miles to
go bail someone out that's a service not
a right
and they don't get paid for it many many
times
and it's fundamentally unfair and it's
it's just simply wrong
so one of our jobs on this committee
during the subcommittee is going to be
to figure out a way to ensure that our
bear Commissioners are paid right now we
are very depleted the numbers of bail
commissioners
and if they all decided to walk off job
tomorrow we'd be in big trouble
um so we need to we need to fix that and
we need to buttress that so that is
something people want to do right now I
can't imagine anyone wanting to do that
in light of the fact that they don't
even get reimbursed
the next issue that we'll be talking
about
is what crimes if a list of crimes that
can or cannot be bailed by a bail
commissioner
that have to be held for a judge
and as part of that we're going to
discuss
and we're going to work with the courts
to see about getting judges to be able
to work on the weekends so we have
on-call judges so there's no reason for
anyone to sit in jail longer than
necessary to be heard and either
released or held
um
currently we don't have that there's
certain issues behind that that we're
going to have to work through for
example a judge is able to do hearings
from home but a clerk is required to
either open the court or and somehow be
able there to take notes or minutes or
in recordings of what happens so we're
going to work with the courts to figure
out what that needs if it requires
another position
because the clerks
and the folks at the court are part of a
union so it's a collective bargaining
issue so we're going to look at that
we're going to hear from the courts
about that and we're going to work on
figuring out a way to do that
I've spoken with one of representatives
from the courts it's doable as always
though it comes down to money
it's my opinion that right now we have
some excess one-time money to spend
we can't encumber a future legislature
it's not a budget but we can fund things
up until
the next budget when the courts would
have to take it over themselves so we're
going to look at that and again I'll be
including Finance in that
and those are the the main issues that
we're going to deal with
at this point I'm happy to hear from any
of the committee that would like to
discuss what their thoughts are on those
and if they have certain other issues
they'd like to discuss
representative Rhodes
Mr chairman thank you for
explaining that very well and um I agree
with everything that you said for the
record and
one of the things that I really think
that we we need to focus on is violation
of bail that has anything to do with a
restraining order domestic violence
um or anything that had any any harm
especially sexual harm with a child so
as long as we can get that in there
pretty much on board
thank you and And to clarify when I said
bail release that that's not only a list
of crimes that's also things that we are
going to discuss whether or not people
should be held over to talk to the judge
such as excessive failures to appear
um this this committee went on a field
trip and I I believe all of us saw the
the number of people that would be
called and they were defaulted they just
didn't show up and they had other
defaults
um so we're going to talk about people
that have trouble finding their way to
the court for their appearances that's a
burden on the system to waste time who
wastes money and it inhibits the uh the
ability of Justice to be carried out
also
um
in regard to that there will be other
issues we discuss whether someone should
be bailed uh for violating restraining
order that's not necessarily a new crime
that's being discussed but it's
something that hasn't been brought up in
any of the bills I believe a violation
of our protective order in and of itself
screams dangerous
so we'll be discussing that as well
representative here gatherer would you
like to
yes I agree 100 with what you're
presenting
um and after having conversations with
others that feel the same way I think
it's great my main concern was holding
people and they haven't been proven to
be guilty of any crime actually you know
so that is a concern but I know that
following offenders definitely would be
helped but that's always already in the
record so
correct I I think that we need to focus
on first we're going to start with the
presumption that everyone is innocent
until proven guilty and then we work on
each person presents an individual
situation to the courts into the justice
system so throwing out a blanket you all
will be held
um is is first of all it's not in
keeping with the Constitution and second
of all it causes Expense It causes
strain on the system but at the same
time we we recognize
the sacrifices and the stresses puts on
law enforcement to arrest people and see
them walking out the door before they
can even finish their police report only
to pick them up a day or two later
but this goes back to my first point on
it
as I pointed out earlier right now you
can be arrested in Manchester on a
serious crime bailed out and picked up
in another part of the state a day later
bailed out again and we scream why are
they letting them out again they're
already on Bill well there's a very good
chance the person who made that decision
has no idea that that person was out on
bail we heard from police officers who
said oftentimes they only found
someone's on bail when they searched
their car and found a bail slip crumbled
up on the floorboard of the car and I
don't think that that's a any way for a
criminal justice system to operate
um I'd like to hear from representative
scitec if you have anything to say
the issues the issues brought up are
excellent uh the especially the I.T I
mean that we look the police and I look
at each other and say is this guy on
bail I think he's Manchester I heard
that's a wonderful wonderful Direction
I want to point out a side comment not
related to this but you might find it
interesting I'm adjusted to the peace
I am sworn before other justices when I
am renewed in order to marry people I am
not sworn
to incarcerate people or keep them
incarcerated isn't that a little strange
I mentioned briefly to representative
cathright that one of the things that we
does that I think needs to be done it's
ancillary to this not to I'm not going
to enlarge on what you've said it's
wonderful
is training for bail Commissioners I
took it seriously I took I've trained
two other bail commissions it took hours
I'm telling you it honest and there's a
laboratory portion I got a guy up my guy
in Salem we got up two in the morning he
came with me to Pal him for usually
pelham's famous for its DUIs they love I
don't know they come from Lowell to
Manchester through it's a great place
DUI capital of Southern New Hampshire
um
and he was with me through I would say a
dozen
veils we get a bail commissioner
handbook but the street is
enlarges that experience that's all I'm
that that's all I wanted to say thank
you thank you representative and and
that is a um actually a very a very good
point and I did already have it in my
notes for uh training but I think also
important is a continuing ed we changed
the laws every year I don't know how
often these bail handbooks are are
updated
um you can respond to that if you there
is an attempt at continuing ed because
every year we meet with our district
court judge but I have found
inconsistencies because when you said
we're short
I have for the team this is patting
myself on the back I have gone to Nashua
I have gone to Raymond I have gone once
to Somersworth the only time I've been
in Somersworth in my life because the
police needed a bail commissioner I did
it for the team
so how short would you say that you are
I can tell you that uh
Salem could use another
week do three towns Salem needs at least
one more and the whole Derry Nashua area
someone else can speak to that but I'll
bet they can use at least two or three
at least that number and and it's really
not a questioning of of funding because
um these positions aren't funded by the
court they're they're basically at this
point volunteer could you address how
often you actually get reimbursed for
your work
I don't want to because I'm
extraordinarily lucky I I have done the
veils in Manchester and it's 50 percent
okay because
this it's terrible the people you see
don't need incarceration they need a
hospital bed and you're looking at this
person it's a life that's in front of
you that's going down the drain
yet you've got to do your job it's a
real conflict when you're I'm not a
counselor but I'm looking at a human
being that's all right
I I I lose
look I Didn't Do It for the money I'm a
pensioner I'm okay but
uh two out of ten
and I'm I'm extraordinarily lucky
indeed
um and and I think that we can New
Hampshire has a probed history of a
volunteer service in our government none
of us here are in it for the money
um so I I would say that the same
probably applies for the bail
Commissioners having said that there is
an expense that they incur and the
inconvenience they concur the incur that
we don't no one's calling us to get up
at three o'clock in the morning and
drive 50 miles to bail someone
um so I think it's very important that
we focus on making sure those folks are
reimbursed and in the training and and
also figuring out a way to bolster those
numbers because without the bill
Commissioners our system would come to a
screeching halt
um thank you for your input
yes I just wanted to say before we get
going that um
thank you
sometimes the the simplest and clearest
Solutions aren't necessarily uh
solutions to the problem and I think
that's one of the things that we've
struggled with with a lot of these bills
um uh they may be clear and Simple
Solutions to a problem
but in some cases they're the wrong
Solutions there are constitutional
issues with uh with some of them there
are also issues related to what
representative scitec raises so what we
don't want to be in is a position where
we're further criminalizing mental
health uh and and I think it's something
that we as we as we start down this path
I think that's one of the things that we
really do need to try to specifically uh
to avoid
um and I do know that a lot of people
have been looking over our shoulders uh
every session I've been in the
legislature we've had to deal with with
Bill bills and a lot of the people who
look over our shoulders are looking at
it from a constitutional perspective so
we have we have a definite obligation to
the people that we need to protect but
one of the things that we also have an
obligation to do is to make sure that
our criminal justice system functions
fairly and effectively for people who
are accused of crimes so we actually are
going to have a lot of our a lot on our
shoulders over the next few weeks uh and
uh and as I said sometimes the clearest
and the simplest Solutions uh are the
wrong ones so I think the challenge for
this committee is to try to come up with
solutions that are as clear and simple
as we can make them but that actually
solve the problem and one of the things
I'm really happy to see you know in the
list uh that representative Roy went
through uh is a is a legitimate attempt
to address some of the systemic things
that are really driving problems with
the bail system
so I think we're we're off to a good
start
thank you representative Muse and I
think as part of the things we need to
discuss is we need to look at are people
being held on crimes that even if
convicted they ultimately would not have
to serve jail
um it seems counterintuitive to me that
someone would be held for a crime that
even if convicted of it there's no jail
sentence so that's one of the things we
need to look at as well which is why
we're going to look at a list of crimes
very carefully
as far as who needs to see a judge and
ensure that there's a judge readily
available so that people aren't held for
extended times for example if someone's
arrested on a Friday
they shouldn't have to wait until Monday
a judge should be able to make a quick
decision via a zoom call whether that
person is a danger or not and and I feel
like that will take some of the burden
off the decision making of the bail
Commissioners when they know that it's
going to be looked at by by someone else
within a short period of time
okay
um so at this point I think what we're
going to do is we're going to talk about
what we're going to do in the upcoming
meeting so that we people have kind of a
feel for
um who as far as people in the audience
here in the gallery who may want to
attend or may not want to attend
um I think the first issue will be
taking up
tomorrow will be
probably we're going to go over our list
of crimes I think that's where we'll
start I wanted to do i t but I I think
I've got a date
in October when the company that
actually did just did this for it was
one of the Carolinas they just redid
their entire court system and that will
be the date we'll take that up and
that'll give us time to get Finance to
come as well so tomorrow
plan on looking at the lists of crimes
that we're going to be discussing I'll
circulate this evening a draft proposal
to the members and we will discuss it
tomorrow at the hearing
and bring your thoughts on that
and then next Thursday I think that will
start with discussing the bill
Commissioners and how they are
reimbursed and we will invite someone
from the court on that day I am working
on a meeting with the Chief Justice of
the New Hampshire Supreme Court for
myself and representative gathright to
bring our proposals the court can't tell
us policy but they can tell us whether
our policy is workable or not so we're
going to kind of try and pick his brain
and thread that needle as far as him
telling us our policy and US imposing
something on the court that just isn't
workable or will clog the justice system
um
and we'll go further on our schedule
after that so those are the next two
days tomorrow and next Thursday is there
anyone here in the audience there is
there in a better word in the audience
as a lark I started to list the fails
that I did yeah I've done about 3 500
Bales and I have coffee books which I'm
willing to bring in you might want to
see what it actually looks like how many
personal recognizants which is the
overwhelming majority what the crimes
are how it just might be an interesting
thing to thumb through if anybody wants
I'll bring them in you can take a look
at them if you like I think that's a
good idea because it's frankly probably
um the best information we could get
because we couldn't go to the court
again because the it system is a mess so
thank you is there anyone um here uh
representative would you like to address
the committee I see you're here probably
thank you thank you Mr chairman
um I just want to say I I really
um I think the points that you guys just
laid out the three points that you guys
are going to work on as a committee are
fantastic
um I talk to a lot of people around the
state officials and citizens and the
state is really looking for us to do
something and um I I'm hopeful after
coming to this meeting this morning that
something's going to be accomplished and
I'm looking forward to seeing what you
guys come up with
thank you representative
um and frankly that was my my point when
I started framing this is I looked back
and I realized as representative Muse
said we seems like we're dealing with a
bail issue um every couple years we're
back at bail back at bill I feel like
um it's time to fix it once and for all
and instead of patching the holes let's
just rebuild the dam and do it right and
I think that would um that would so far
to help our citizens I see a a former
bail commissioner would you like to
I know you I'd probably put you on the
my name is Trixie LeFevre I was a bail
commissioner up until August 31st of
this year when I resigned at the time of
my resignation I was owed for 2022 and
2023 over fifteen thousand dollars most
of my calls were to the Manchester
Police Department
um I feel as it was there was a
disconnect with the bail commissioner
community and the payment process I
appreciate the fact that you were all on
the right track with putting bail
Commissioners as part of your committee
charge
um it's and I do know that at one point
in time within the past five years there
were probably over 125 bail
Commissioners and last I knew we were
down to about 85. so there does need to
be a fix to the situation so that the
state of New Hampshire can go back to
where they were which is to provide the
service to the police departments
so that the officers are not held inside
the police departments and not able to
patrol and keep the citizens safe so I
just appreciate all that I will be
continuing to attend because I was
raised to say to think that I'm going to
see it to the end I've been here since
2019 and it would be nice to know that
the bail commissioner Community is being
looked after so thank you very much I
thank you and the institutional
knowledge that you bring we will
definitely be using it over the course
of the next three or four weeks so be
prepared to have your brain picked okay
thank you very much thank you is there
anyone else would like to speak
Frank
uh Mr chairman members of the committee
thank you silly New Hampshire
um I just
really I wanted to say I appreciate the
time that this committee has put into
this issue has not been distracted by
rhetoric has been really dedicated to
looking at what the facts are looking at
the law currently allows and so I really
appreciate that you all are taking this
very kind of thoughtful approach to this
and I hope you all see us as a resource
throughout this process and um yeah
we'll be here each week and appreciate
your time
seeing no one else anyone else on the
seeing none I think that's all we really
have for today I apologize for the short
meeting but I felt like it was important
to kind of set the groundwork on what we
will be doing
um some of you may appreciate being able
to leave quickly some of you maybe drove
a long way in or angry with me but I
feel like we need to be um we need to be
prepared and not just especially in
light of the way that I'd like to go
forward with this one piece at a time I
want to give you all an opportunity to
kind of prep for it so that when you
come to the next meeting you have some
thoughts on it rather than having to
come up with them off the cuff
um did you want to say something or no
okay with that I see nothing further
then I will see you all tomorrow morning
at 10 o'clock and be prepared to discuss
crimes that should or should not be
available I I just want to note I am
going to try and reach out to the
members of the Senate
um our counterparts and see if anyone
would like to attend what I don't want
to do is have this committee spend a
month working really hard to have it go
to the other side of the of the
bicameral chamber to have it tossed out
so I'd like their support and buy in
input early on I see this as a joint
effort not US versus them and I feel
like what fell apart
uh this previous session was unfortunate
but out of it became something good
we're gonna we're gonna instead of just
passing that fix and moving on we're
going to look at the whole system so
I'll be reaching out to them this
afternoon hopefully we'll be seeing some
of them soon with that I closed the